[Musique]
bien sûr le débat sur france 24 la reine
elizabeth fête ses 70 ans de règne le
jubilé de platine une longévité
exceptionnelle puisque la souveraine a
dépassé de 7 ans le règne de son arrière
arrière grand mère la reine victoria
quatre jours de cérémonies mais aussi
des fêtes de rue sont organisées dans
tout le pays ce long week-end et fériés
pour les britanniques il habite de a été
acclamé au balcon du palais de
buckingham aujourd'hui par des dizaines
de milliers de personnes les
britanniques alors est ce qu'ils aiment
leur reine elizabeth ii ou leur
monarchie constitutionnelle ce jubilé de
platine marque-t-il la fin d'une époque
on évoquera aussi la célébration de ce
jubilé en france emmanuel macron qui a
ravivé la flamme à l'arc de triomphe en
pleine tension entre paris et londres
après les événements au stade de france
et puis à la succession de la reine
elizabeth qui sera assurée par
l'héritier du trône charles son règne
sera-t-il différent jubilé platine la
fin d'une époque on en débat avec mes
invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir mes
côtés caroline pigozzi bonsoir on soul
est journaliste et auteure votre dernier
livre pourquoi eux ils ont fait notre
époque et c'est chez plon bienvenue et
on parle la reine d'angleterre ni un
grand championnat vous avez à chapitre
donc sur la reine elizabeth bienvenue
dans le débat philippe toulat
chroniqueur france24 bienvenue à filer
pomme nous avons également avec thau
pierrick j'ai bon soir journaliste
spécialiste des têtes couronnées à
vanity fair hauteur de prince william la
vraie vie d'un futur roi ça vient de
sortir aux éditions du rocher bienvenue
à vous également on devra avoir avec
nous en direct de londres
dollis mcshane de nice mcshane ancien
ministre travailliste des affaires
européennes qu'on cherche à joindre on
espère qu'il va qu'il va donc apparaître
dans ce débat avant de débattre en tout
cas je vous propose un retour en images
un retour en images de cette première
journée de célébration de ce jubilé de
platine de la reine elizabeth ii et
c'est avec laura roudaut
70 ans de règne pour une reine toujours
aussi populaire elizabeth 2 96 ans
appuyée sur sa canne et acclamé par la
foule massée devant le palais de
buckingham la reine célèbre ce jeudi son
jubilé de platine le plus long règne de
l'histoire de la monarchie britannique
depuis la reine victoria
soixante trois ans à la tête de l'empiré
britannique sur le célèbre balcon au
côté d'elisabeth 2 son fils le prince
charles qui lui succèdera et son épouse
camilla mais aussi le prince william son
époux skate et leurs enfants
les grands absents le prince harry et
son épouse mégane n'ont pas été
autorisés à saluer la foule sur le
balcon tout comme le prince andrew le
fils de la reine accusé d'agression
sexuelle en lien avec l'affairé ben
stein en fin de matinée les membres de
la monarchie britannique était arrivé au
palais en calèche image rare depuis la
pandémie de trois générations royal
réunis dans un carrosse sur le môle
beaucoup de spectateurs ont dormi ici
nous venons d'un peu partout manchester
de vol birmingham une de mes filles
vient même de paris pour que l'on soit
tous ensemble
nous sommes arrivés ici vers 6 heures du
matin pour être au premier rang et avoir
la meilleure vue je suis déguisé en
garde en vue je suis ici pour célébrer
le jubilé de la tient
j'ai hâte de voir la reine au balcon
avec la famille royale c'est la première
fois que j'assiste à ça l'héritier de la
couronne le prince charles a passé en
revue les troupes du défilé militaire
lors du salut aux couleurs car la reine
ne monte plus à cheval
pourtant c'est bien elle que les
britanniques vont fêter quatre jours
durant plus que la monarchie ce que
célèbrent les britanniques c'est le
destin incroyable d'une femme qui
appartient à la fois à l'histoire et au
quotidien de chacun
philippe tort là c'est fou ce que vous
aimez votre reine les britanniques et on
se demandait ce que c'est elizabeth 2
que vous aimez ou est ce que c'est la
monarchie constitutionnelle je pense sur
des points qui vous parlais mais pour
une grande partie de la population que
vous soyez royalistes ou pas royaliste
vous aimez la monarchie ou pas vous et
républicain je pense que tout le monde
est uni dans cette admiration pour cette
dame arrêt avec ses 70 ans de règne
cette règne presque sans un faux pas on
peut évidemment citer deux ou trois mais
en 70 ans sans titre et devra c'est à
dire ça veut dire
l'absence lors du décès de diana
le chute de popularité dont après
l'année l'année horribilis 92 l'incendié
au château de windsor elle a accepté de
payer pour la première fois les des
impôts sur le revenu et puis on 66,6 eu
une désastre pays de galles où il ya eu
119 rond fond qui est située à la tarde
d y aller et elle a toujours regretté
mais à l'époque il disait je ne vais pas
y aller tout de suite parce que j'avais
peur que les gens les moins gradés mois
et par les parents des pauvres enfants
décédés mais donc vous à perm un
parcours a priori sans talent sans
faille et est quelqu'un qui il faut le
dire
inspiré l'admiration par seulement des
britanniques mais du monde entier donc
c'est plus la reine que la monarchie
constitutionnelle c'est le personnage de
la reine et sont liés il n'y a pas de
dinde d'un côté la reine et de l'autre
côté la monarchie sans la monarchie aura
pas la reine et son arrêt n'y aura par
la monarchie donc donc évidemment je
pense que les britanniques sont attachés
à la monarchie et on n'est pas comme
beaucoup de gens disent le jour où la
reine décédera halak en mai 81 saison
demain ce sera une république en grande
bretagne non je n'y crois pas du tout on
y revient dans panique sont quand même
très attachés à la monarchie
comme ils sont attachés peut-être plus à
elisabeth deux tiers et que j'aille à
cet amour des britanniques pour leur
reine malgré alors philippe parlait de
3,1 père mais enfin bon il ya tout de
même des phrases que chez les windsor et
windsor que d'ailleurs georges si ça
plaît la firme alors il ya l'adultère de
charles diana camilla le prince andrew
qui accuse et aurait même de viol il ya
les rivalités fratricides entre williams
et et harry il ya eu le drame de la mort
de lady est malgré tout il ya cet amour
pour bien se tenir et aujourd'hui je
pense qu'on a aussi essayé d'oublier
tout ça c'est pour ça que d'ailleurs
harry et megan était là aujourd'hui
enfin ils ne se sont pas montrés au
balcon mais on sait qu'ils étaient là il
était au déjeuner après dans l'intimité
du palais de buckingham
donc ils seront peut-être au balcon pour
une deuxième sortie au balcon surprise
dimanche il y aura une autre parade -
officiel mais avec des artistes des
musiciens il y aura peut-être une sortie
au balcon surprise avec une famille
agrandie donc peut-être une image de
réconciliation
andrew lui n'est pas là il ne sera même
pas là à la messe de demain à saint pol
donc on voit qu'on a essayé de le mettre
de côté donc on dit qu'il a co vie
bizarrement coïncidence là il a eu copie
donc il ne sera pas là pour la suite du
week end met aux gens disent que je
rappelle qu est accusé de viols sur
mineurs dans leur l'aleps tarifs stein
bien sûr mais aujourd'hui plus qu'un
engouement vers l'arène on a vu une
sorte de tendresse et une tendresse à
ces nouvelles parce que avant la reine
elle avait quand même cette image assez
froid de marque solide flegmatique ce
flegme anglais celle qui était l'icône
la grand-mère de l'angleterre c'était
queen mum jusqu'en 2002 un peu marrant
qui portait ses tailleurs très coloré
aujourd'hui elizabeth 2 les anglais en
parlait avec des termes très différent
il parlait de cette petite dame de 96
enfin un tout petit on les disait les
toutes petites allées tout fragile on
sentait une nouvelle tendresse du peuple
britannique pour la reine plus qu'un
engouement c'est une tendresse caroline
pigozzi
elizabeth est devenue reine à 25 ans
était une fonction à laquelle elle
n'était pas vraiment préparé s'il est
aussi populaire est ce que c'est d'abord
dû à la longévité ou est-ce que c'est dû
à sa personnalité là bas est
intergénérationnel parce que maintenant
et puis je crois qu elle l est dans le
paysage depuis toujours
et puis au fond si c'était un roi il
serait sans doute moins populaire que l
en reine voyez il ya une espèce de
douceur c'est une femme on peut plus
facilement s'identifier
elle a eu quatre enfants elle a eu des
problèmes comme tout le monde comme dans
toutes les familles où on s'engueule
chacun peut y trouver ce qu'ils
cherchent voilà surtout sur une telle
longévité
et puis elle est gelée d'angleterre
c'est un mythe de toute façon la famille
d'angleterre qu'elle est la famille qui
est depuis si longtemps voyez il est
complètement ne serait-ce que de les
portraits tout ça enfin il fait partie
de la vie des gens et les chefs de
famille et chef d'état finale chefs
religieux aussi chefs religieux russes
elle fait partie de l'histoire et elle
fait partie du quotidien en quelque
sorte on me dit que quasiment tous les
britanniques ont un jour rêvé de la
reine et en même temps elle fait ses
études déjà une légende vivante 70 ans
de règne vous imaginez quasiment tous
les britanniques n'ont connu cale sur le
trône alors on n'est pas dans une vie
vous savez vous des travaux passer une
moyenne basse urbaine sur autant
d'années de pouvoir un philippe sella
rennes dont duale et chef du
commonwealth 54 pays presque tous
d'ailleurs des anciens territoires de
l'empiré britannique et on sait qu'il y
ait accordé une grande importance
c'est encore une signification
aujourd'hui le common word c'est ce que
c'est grâce à la reine grâce à la reine
en partie c'est certain
on peut contester du côté des caraïbes
alors donc bon il faut quand même
comprendre de quoi il s'agit là on à 54
pays du commonwealth qui sont pros
presque à la totalité des anciens
colonie britannique lourdes l'empiré
britannique était quand même toujours de
rigueur quand la reine est devenue reine
en 1952 la décolonisation a eu lieu plus
tard enfin c'était ça va commencer déjà
mais ça s'est terminé sous sous
elizabeth 2 et donc il y en a 16 ans
cours de ces pays qui ont les abeilles 2
comme chef d'état
évidemment il y en a certains on a eu
les les limes bermudes qui récemment ont
décidé de pas référendum de ne plus
avoir les maîtres d'eux comme chef
d'état il est certain qu'à la fin de son
règne quand charles deviendrait roi je
pense que l'australie probablement le
canada et d'autres pays vont dire
maintenant il est bien pour nous de
couper les ponts avec la famille royale
mais ça va pas d'élément quitté le
commonwealth parce que comme moi au
sénégal quand même une époque 7 rennes
on a l'impression que ça se mette une
époque révolue presque oui mais on la
garde pas sympathie pour elle et pas
solidarité avec elle parce que vu l'âge
qu'elle a la longévité de son règne les
époques qu'elle a traversée avec tous
ces pays
il est il est considéré que couper les
ponts maintenant quand elle à 96 ans à
la fin de son règne ça se rate pas bien
vu donc on attend l'arrivée de charles
sur le troll est en ce moment là on
verra bien donc comment le commonwealth
va se constituer à ce moment là mais je
pense que les membres du club dont il y
en a cinquante quatre vont pas pour
ainsi dire quitter les corbeaux noirs
ils peuvent mais je pense que il y aura
des clients qui vont peut-être ne plus
vouloir la famille royale comme chef
d'état mais ils vont pas pour inciter à
quitter le com - en même temps on dirait
que j'ai la monarchie donc elle a encore
un sens au royaume uni malgré alors que
tout se décide au têt nombreux thèmes
comme on dit là où se trouve le premier
ministre oui elle a un sens dans l'unité
justement pendant 70 ans de règne
elizabeth ii a voulu cette unité que ce
soit l'unité du royaume uni l'unité du
commonwealth et là on voit que cette
unité elle se désagrège et il y avait
quelque chose d'assez particulier vous
savez le dernier la dernière ouverture
du parlement c'est charles pour la
première fois qui a fait ce discours du
trône et ce discours du trône il venait
quelques jours après des élections
locales en écosse et en irlande avec une
poussée très importante des
indépendantistes et vous savez les
écossais par exemple il voudrait quitter
le royaume uni peut-être rejoindre de
nouveaux l'union européenne et on l'a on
leur a posé la question si vous
rejoignez l'union européenne est ce que
vous voulez garder la reine en chef
d'état ils ont dit oui bien sûr qu'on
veut garder la reine bien et comme vous
disiez ils sont très attachés à cette
figure par contre est-ce que vous aurez
charles en chef d'état ça c'est moins
sûr et will i am encore moins sur
finalement là encore elizabeth ii et
chef du commonwealth charles normalement
devrait l'être mais ce n'est pas sur
williams a été interrogé il ya peu est
ce que vous serez il a dit je ne suis
pas sûr parce que ça pourrait très bien
être un président australien qui devient
chef du commonwealth n'est pas
obligatoirement le souverain britannique
qui devient voir parler la succession
quel est son héritage caroline pigozzi à
cette reine d'abord elle a fait
apprendre la géographie foot c'est un
pays où elle règne à toute l'angleterre
son héritage c'est la tenue c'est de ne
jamais se laisser aller ces deux jamais
rien montré finalement et c'est d'être à
l'aise avec tous les chefs d'état de
tous les pays c'est d'être un exemple
justement intergénérationnel et quand on
parle de l'angleterre on parle pas de
milieu on dit pas à ouidah va c'est la
reine d'angleterre il n'y a pas de sujet
et ce qui est amusant c'est de la voir
ce qui est fascinant c'est de la voir se
promener que sa couronne sur la tête
parce qu'une chose qui m'a absolument
ébloui parce qu'elle marche avec sa
couronne sur la tête que vous irez au
marché voyez ces espèces de
décontraction cessa jeu malgré tout de
savoir un savoir faire extraordinaire
une façon de sourire ni trop ni pas
assez je me souviens il y avait un dîner
à l'elysée où le président chirac la
touche est ce qui n'est pas convenable
parce que touche pas une reine n'est pas
la reine d'angleterre mais elle était
tout aussi calme souriante on a
l'impression qu'elle ne s'énerve jamais
ça c'est formidable c'est un réflexe
formidable c'est peut-être pas vrai
peut-être que
mais c'est l'impression qu'elle donne
c'est son image lire il faut sur la
longévité il n'y a pas une photo où elle
se met les doigts enfin je deviens voyez
où elle se gratte le nez il n'ya pas
formidable c'est toujours juste vous
savez il faut remonter longtemps pour
comprendre
l'attitude de la reine et la mentalité
de la reine et tout ça c'est une
personnage il faut dire des années 30
c'est quelqu'un qui a grandi avant la
guerre qui a collé la deuxième guerre
mondiale qui a connu les difficultés du
peuple et donc elle est là cette notion
que je dois tout faire pour le pays pour
le bien-être des autres et donc c'est
quelque chose qui est en voie de
disparition aujourd'hui quand on voit le
comportement des abris et mégane par
exemple qui font tout pour eux-mêmes et
que qui pourront simplement pas du tout
aux autres la reine s'est complètement
le contraire elle ne demande jamais rien
à personne et il ya une phrase en
anglais c'est l'être humain et beats que
je fasse le nécessaire moi même le
maximum que je peux faire pour apporter
ma petite pierre sol ensemble pour
l'ensemble du pays et c'est ça la force
de cette reine ses 5 îles à la donne
envie de continuer et donc je pense que
celle là où les gens comprennent que
c'est quelqu'un qui vraiment à donner sa
vie pour les aux ailes à 10 k et le fait
en 1947 elle n'a jamais failli cette
règle a eu des hauts et des bas
évidemment mais mais elle est restée
constante et dans ce monde de fou qui
change tout on il ya des guerres il ya
des matins qui a les problèmes dans
l'économie elle choses qui changent
jamais c'est la reine elle est toujours
constante elle est toujours là on
al'impression généralement que quand on
voit la reine comment on voit
aujourd'hui et bien tout va bien se
passer et finalement tout va bien
sa dette en tant que chef de famille ce
n'est pas tout rose on sait qu'il ya des
tensions avec charles on sait qu' il ya
eu des tensions aussi avec la génération
d'après donc mégane et et harry est ce
que c'est vraiment et ce qu'elle incarne
ce ce côté chef de famille véritablement
ou de manière aussi sereine que le
décrit philippe quand il parle plus de
la chef d'état finalement le vrai chef
de famille c'était le prince philippe il
avait au moins ce rôle parce qu'il ne
supportait pas ce second rôle dans la
sphère publique donc ils avaient au
moins le premier rôle dans la sphère
privée
la reine on lui a d'ailleurs souvent
reproché de se comporter trop en chef
d'état est parfois pas assez en chef de
famille dans certains dans certains cas
et puis parfois par exemple à la mort de
diana on lui a reproché de se comporter
en chef de famille et pas en chef d'état
parce que vous savez elle avait mis ses
elle avait voulu protéger ses deux
petits enfants harry et william avant
tout elle avait préféré rester une
semaine à balmoral et ne pas revenir à
londres et là on avait dit mais que fait
que fait la reine que fait le chef
d'état justement on va pas on va aller à
paris on va regarder ces images parce
qu'on célèbre aussi les 70 ans de règne
de la reine elizabeth ii à paris
emmanuel macron s'est rendu à l'arc de
triomphe pour raviver la flamme il était
accompagné de l'ambassadrice du royaume
uni en france mais n'a rawlings ils ont
déposé conjointement une gerbe au pied
de la tombe du soldat inconnu
emmanuel macron d'ailleurs entendu
également l'hymne de britanniques god
save the queen j'aimerais bien qu'on ait
les images god save the queen joué par
la fanfare donc du vol richmond of
scotland et puis ensuite il ya eu la
marseillaise donc voilà emmanuel macron
avait d'ailleurs posté une vidéo sur le
site du gouvernement et sur son compte
twitter je vous propose d'ailleurs un
extrait de cette vidéo
vous êtes notre ami notre si proches
alliés notre exemple de service aux
autres vous célébrez aujourd'hui c'est
célébrer l'amitié sincère et profonde
qui unit nos deux pays et votre
dévouement pour la servir
votre majesté j'ai le privilège de vous
adresser au nom du peuple français mes
félicitations les plus sincères pour
votre jubilé de platine donc une pesée
où il a fait également ce message en
anglais également est ce que finalement
il peut apaiser les tensions est ce
qu'elle peut apaiser les tensions entre
paris et londres la reine elle était
très francophile et francophone oui ps
pour voir des chevaux et puis justement
le plus dans ma croûte offert un cheval
comme vous savez aussi de la garde
républicaine et quand on passe juste ce
faubourg saint-honoré donc à l'ambassade
de grande bretagne à côté de l'elysée il
ya un grand portrait aujourd'hui dollar
est très joli et est ce que
manuel macro et sas et je crois pas
qu'il a une baguette magique et je crois
que ça s'est un peu compliqué parce
qu'on revient finalement sur ce sujet là
on en vient la politique européenne non
je crois que ont fait la fête et puis le
lendemain la politique et la politique
ça je suis moins certaine et il peut
créer un climat mais après tout c'est un
gouvernement il ya un premier ministre
s'est pas exactement à buckingham que se
prennent les décisions politiques l'osé
bleus s'il savait elle est ce qu'elle
peut apaiser parce que là effectivement
on voyait le grand message d' emmanuel
macron de fraternité on revient à la
même situation dont on parlait tout à
l'heure un savoie qui a cet amour 7
cette admiration pour cette femme et je
pense qu'il manioc macron lancôme comme
nous tous mais elle est pour rien dans
la situation de la grande bretagne et
les relations entre la grande-bretagne
et la france qu'elle reste de l'union
européenne tout ça c'est le travail de
son gouvernement de boris johnson et
elle
n'interviendra pas dans le débat
politique pour la simple raison que elle
ne peut pas elle ne veut pas pas elle
peut mais elle ne veut pas parce que
elle dit toujours le jour où je ne
reviens j'ai dit si je prends une
décision j'annonce que je veux je vais
diviser le peuple rom deux entre ceux
qui me soutiennent et ceux qui me
soutiennent pas c'est pas mon rôle mon
rôle c'est de dette est la personne
fédérateur qui qui va
galvaniser le peuple britannique donc je
ne peux pas dire ce que je pense il faut
que je reste silencieux et si pour ça
qu'on n'a jamais entendu la reine
parlait elle donne jamais d'interview on
peut parler posé de question on peut pas
savoir ce qu'elle pense parce qu'elle
donne des rats par dessus de manière et
laisse gouverner le gouvernement est peu
dako pas d'accord avec eux mais on saura
pas ce qu'elle pense pierre et que
j'allais français ont quand même une une
sorte de relation paradoxale avec la
reine d'angleterre on a l'impression
qu'ils aiment la république donc ils le
disent mais en même temps il s'intéresse
à la royauté britannique il ya qu à voir
évidemment le succès de la presse people
il ya un paradoxe dans dans le sentiment
que peuvent ressentir les français à
l'égard de ce pas reine elizabeth et de
la royauté britannique ce paradoxe c'est
finalement la reine qui en parle lors de
sa dernière visite officielle à paris en
2014 elle est venue inaugurer un marché
aux fleurs sur l'île saint louis qui a
été rebaptisé d'ailleurs marché aux
fleurs elizabeth 2 elle était
accompagnée d'anne hidalgo il y avait
une foule de français venus scander des
vive la reine des vive la reine
elizabeth ii s'est retourné vers anne
hidalgo elle a dit mais comment ce
peuple qui a coupé la tête de ces rois
fut scandé des vive la reine donc oui
c'est un vrai paradoxe mais les français
ont un lien très particulier avec
elizabeth 2 déjà parce qu'on le disait
elle-même est très francophile
francophone elle a appris le français
tout petit queen mum sa mère était aussi
parlait un français impeccable prince
charles parle aussi très bien français
le prince william et le prince harry
quasiment pas parce que diana trouvé ça
un peu ringard de leur faire apprendre
le français il avait de l a appris le
français avec madame de bellaigue qui
était belge pourtant mais elle par la
très très bon forcé puis elle avait une
admiration sans borne pour françois
mitterrand il s'entendait très bien
justement on va on a retrouvé un petit
morceau d'archivés on la voit pas les
français avec françois mitterrand on va
regarder
la tradition anglo saxonne
est un peu à la tradition latine en
europe ce que l'huile est au vinaigre
il faut les deux pour faire la sauce
sinon la salade et mal assaisonner car
les piteuses est donc un discours en
français on revient effectivement sur
ses liens donc elle avait aussi avec en
particulier avec françois mitterrand oui
ce qui est drôle c'est de voir qu'elle
est absolument
éblouissante ces bijoux sont éblouis
sauf savez ce qui est drôle dans cet
univers socialisme mais françois
mitterrand aimait l'histoire et ils
étaient quelques il était féministe et
pour lui il était trop extraordinaire je
prends une femme qui était depuis si
longtemps comme ça qui tenait le cap et
finalement qui était au dessus des
partis enfin et comme au fond lui aurait
voulu être absolument dessus des partis
puis il avait quelque chose de marque de
royal françois mitterrand en était
un finalement il est un souverain
socialiste mais il était quand même on
ne discutait pas sa souveraineté il
était d'une autorité
comme ça et donc oui s'entendait bien
desquels il n'y avait pas de discussions
il aurait aimé que chez lui ses
ministres ne discute pas ce soir
denis macshane nous a rejoint par
téléphone malheureusement et non pas en
duplex anciens ministres travail et des
affaires européennes bonsoir à vous de
nice mcshane
vous prenez un peu l'émission en route
alors j'ai envie de vous demander est-ce
qu'elle joue quand même un rôle
diplomatique dans la relation entre la
france et la grande-bretagne la reine
elizabeth 2
reculons elle crée des dépôts n'est pas
pourtant l'entente cordiale
et que le différend après la rocade ou
la jupette de pau lyon arif leroy et 3
wii et donc à part que deux secondes à
mai le pape alors tu habites
tic
2008 on en avait fait alliance pour le
premier rang mondial de gestion mondiale
et caetera et donc et les deux têtes
elle adore tout ce qui est français
l'été on a discuté sur hippiques effet
que cavalière de renault et les lupien
françois du terreau mais franches aux 1
messieurs 8 071 charb extraordinaire
départ et la reine doit être très
prudents cette charte et paris ces
hôpitaux dit que c'est peut-être vous
aiderait les on les sort peut-être
socialistes français c'est aussi
subit trop dans le président robert half
un peu près la même qu ait l'arrêt tu
sais pas comment j'allais quand ils
n'arrêtent pas après un mètre
et il fait exactement surpris les fans
commençaient à et les fuites et
les verts français je vous interromps de
nice mais que je ne voyais pas les
images viens de voir des images
d'archivés on a vu en fait les
présidents américains des filets on a vu
ronald reagan et puis on a vu barack
obama ça fait effectivement toute une
histoire philippe talleu ses 70 ans de
règne elle alors montceau les français
il me semble qu'elle a vu combien
combien de présidents de la république
combien dit président de la république
il y en a qui a touché c'était jacques
chirac vous souvenez de la touchait d'un
carrosse il accède en carrosse
se fait pas il ya très peu de mourir
plus personne qui veut dire à qui
devrait donc retrouver les américains
donc effectivement on a vu ces images
avec ronald reagan donc ces images
avec l'écurie qui elle a eu une certaine
intimité plus qu'avec d'autres
présidents américains on le voit tous
sont donc ces images à cheval ou chatel
win the rock sombre mais bon le rigolo
si c'était un homme qui aimait bien les
autres qu'ils étaient capables d'aller
vers les autres et je pense que cette
complicité avec la reine était un peu la
même chose que l habite rue avec
françois mitterrand mais elle a quand
même une expérience très importante
depuis harry truman le premier président
américain qu'il a connu jusqu'à
aujourd'hui elle a rencontré le dernier
c'était dans les trompes et elle a connu
tous les points mais l'isf on s'est même
encore comme ancien
lavoir à windsor
dernière et donc ella ella ont reconnu
vincent auriol premier avant qu'elle
soit rennes jusqu'à eaux vives et mâcon
et winston churchill jusqu'à pollution
sont donc qui peut dire qu'ils ont cette
expérience diplomatique
c'est extraordinaire vous vouliez dire
quelque chose
oui quand vous parlez
de très belles histoires
vallourec a décidé de pallier
petit il crée dada crédac peut-être en
france et il n'aimait pas tout car le
collège à cochons quoi est dû ce cas un
homme serein formes et les couleurs de
mon public et c'était près du camp de
loin tant que chef d'état était sa
majesté et la reine a fait appeler à
bagdad après le 8e venait le voir et des
bons sons purs aux sons lov et pas
d'autres dans la pièce d écouter et
madame le prévenu vous pouvez
m'expliquer pourquoi le président des
etats-unis a décidé quand on voit un
bébé il
est hors du poker est là et a dû subir
un port il s'étiole le second tour et de
mai a insisté ils doivent recevoir dans
l'autre à pompe et là l
électronique santé voir mais on est bon
les plus quand on avait peut-être les le
premier ministre indien très cultivé
que je le président bittar oh là là les
acteurs là ses favoris bref j'ai
donc favori elle détestait 1 le
producteur ou le palu bliss le chef du
gouvernement communiste de roumanie de
ceausescu
parce que les détenus et un fils tate
faire venir avec lui quelqu'un pour qui
ces plats avec louis il est mort hélas
la red hat ou les libyens et les plats
de pâques je parle un bon que les avaler
et puis un peu exagéré c'était pas pas
convenable américains font ça aussi que
président des états unis a toujours un
goûteur est content parce que ça n'a pas
plu à la reine c'est ce que dit ce match
elle est quand même la femme du
président des états unis est allé voir
madame chirac en corrèze et avait un
goûteur aussi donc vous sortez avec
tous les présidents j'ai bien que j'ai
avec tous les présidents français ça
s'est plutôt bien passé et on se
souvient m nicolas sarkozy carla bruni
qui avait été parfait quand il était
allé voir la reine à londres carla bruni
sa révérence avait été saluée par tous
les journaux britanniques ce qui
s'appelait préparent assez rare le seul
avec qui ça s'est un petit peu moins
bien passé c'est peut-être françois
hollande parce que elle n'avait pas
supporté lors d'un dîner d'état qui le
portent un toast avec une coupe de
champagne vide elle avait trouvé ça elle
a trouvé qu'elle avait trouvé que
c'était vraiment une faute de goût alors
70 ans de règne c'est aussi bien sur le
moment d'évoquer la succession
l'héritier du trône c'est donc charles
charles prince de galles il sera il est
suivi par son fils aîné william duc de
cambridge puis par l'aîné de ses enfants
philippe torres que la succession est
prête oui depuis longtemps parce que bon
il ya une question que tout bon mot
pause mais d'une façon régulière et je
n'arrive jamais à expliquer cela une
fois pour toutes choses que ça revient
comme un boomerang est-ce que je suis
aussi un roi ou est ce que la cour on
passerait directement de la reine
elizabeth ii à williams alors je dis mes
chats ont ça fait soixante dix ans qu'il
attend ce rôle il ya 73 ans à 74 74 ans
il
il est à la l'âge de la retraite pour un
travail qui n'a pas encore pu
il est la personne qui attend depuis le
plus longtemps val de loire m'attend
depuis le plus longtemps de l'histoire
il est peu probable qu'après sept à
trente aussi longue qui dira pas
finalement j'ai pas envie donc oui on
peut pas l'écarter de la ligne la lignée
des sites de succession est donc ce sera
lui le prochain roi il faut savoir qu'il
a comme on vient de deshaies 73 74 ans
cette année ça va pas et pour très
longtemps qu'ils sont rois enfin ça
dépend ces jeunes
que sont
la période enfin comme edward c'est ton
mais ne sont injustes comme ils ne sont
dix après la reine victoria qui a régné
pendant neuf ans bon évidemment tout le
monde et mike richards vu le plus
longtemps possible mais ce serait plus
williams qui va prendre la relève
derrière william qui beaucoup plus
formaté beaucoup plus dans le moule
d'elizabeth ii beaucoup plus classique
conservateur surtout kate sa femme qui
n'a jamais fait un faux pas qui est
extrêmement bien préparé pour le rôle
beaucoup mieux que derrière n'a par
exemple à l'époque où est appliquée
charles donc je n'ai pas de de problème
ni d'inquiétudes concernant la
succession de la famille jour j attendez
attendez pardonnez moi vous n'êtes pas
d'accord dennis mcshane je vous donne la
parole dans un instant juste budget en
effet ce sera un rôle d'un règne de
transition on peut même penser que le
prince jean de transition dont parle de
chat va régner main dans la main avec
william parce qu'on le voit williams
aujourd'hui il a un rôle de premier plan
il n'a pas du tout un rôle de son groupe
l'enfant qui est envoyé par la reine
pour les voyages officiels les plus
importants comme tout récemment aux
caraïbes c'est william parce que c'est
la meilleure vitrine de l'institution
monarchique et comme vous le disiez
elizabeth ii est la forge et william à
son image avec ses fameux déjeuner du
dimanche en tête à tête alors que
charles il ne lui ressemble pas il est
trop progressiste il est trop poète il
est reparti tout
cela
je veux juste réagir d'abord caroline
pigozzi alesi moi je dois dire que
charles d'angleterre finalement il a été
le premier à parler d'écologie quand
personne n'en parlait quand personne ne
s'y intéressait son côté progressiste et
oui non mais je dire c'était un truc on
regardait un peu comme un fou à l'époque
et maintenant tout le monde a suivi
quand même non et donc maintenant qu'il
est
visionnaire et c était beaucoup dans
l'air du temps est-ce qu'il serait
peut-être plus moderne que la reine
actuelle de nice mcshane
écouter
avec papa du propos que j'ai bientôt ton
gameboy après problème de la succession
le prince charles quand tu t'es pas
maquillée pour la télévision par est
plus âgée que la rai rap et assure
qu'elle va durer
l'âge de faiblesses auxquelles incombe
donc à il aura 80 ans quand il accède au
trône ainsi donc lui continue à l'âge de
son papa le prince philippe est piquée
de bouc c'est à dire à l'âge de 99 ans
il va être l'apollon 20 ans c'est à dire
que le prince william devient le wpt à
l'âge de 65 ans et son fils de petit
prince ont maintenant huit au bâton
hostile jusqu'à ses 75
la
monarchie au carré bonnat fille qu'il
avait toujours l'image de lettres
dynamique que dans les années 50 60 70 à
pleurer ici est si bonne heure très
droite
donc il ya un vrai problème de
succession ne peut pas l'écarter sur
l'idée que très progressif et l'ex qui
suppliait chose je dis pas qu'on sert
d'être réactionnaire oui la bonne idée
de l'écologie les personnes utiliser
autant des jets privés aux tons et des
voitures 2 crytek donc il ya quelques
petites et cas il est bien chanter les
chansons père n'est pas pratique la vie
perd donc sa chance et
il est ancré avec le bail et des autres
villes à battre pour être la république
et tu séparer de faire inscrire cette
visite leur acquis que secret c'est pas
pour quel contrat dans les journaux
britanniques philipper donc si on écoute
d'un speech and cette succession à
risque tout de même d'être compliqué est
ce que ça veut dire oui finalement les
britanniques pourrait basculer vers une
république je suis d'accord danny
smagghe shane corps on peut pas
évidemment prévoit quel âge quelqu'un va
décéder elle va pas dit abdiqué la reine
ne l'a
jamais
la ligne déjà accession et garantit donc
sur williams et puis georges mais on
sait pas à quel âge
serwa vont arriver sur le troll et
espérons qu'ils vont survivre pour
pouvoir y accéder on sait je ne peux pas
prédire l'avenir mais la reine elle peut
s'en aller demain s'il voudrait
dire mais peut dire j'ai fait le travail
j'ai fait le boulot je suis quand même
assurer la succession de la famille et
donc je veux partir tranquille que ce
que tu pas après moi tout ça va dit que
messi donnait ce match n que justement
et maintenant il va y avoir une image
fait un peu vieillissante de ces
politiciens aussi mais on connaissait
d'ennemis il a peut-être raison mais on
peut pas
souvent parce qu'on peut pas prédire à
quel moment quelqu'un va décéder
je laisserai relais c'est agir pièces et
billets d'accidents dans l'histoire du
royaume on le voit avec édouard 8 c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que les rênes parce
qu'elle ne devait pas être reine donc on
ne peut pas prédire déjà écrire toute
l'histoire jusqu'aux prince george
caroline pigozzi un commentaire là
dessus est ce que savait ce qu'on dit à
rome au vatican on dit le temps et
galante homme puis voilà ça prend le
temps que ça prend évidemment c'est
imprévisible comme on peut simplement
peu trop savoir il peut se faire écraser
de ma part par une moto il peut mais
est-ce que la fin finalement du règne
d'elizabeth ii va s'ouvrir sur un rail
pics qui se soit lui celui de charles ou
celui effectivement mouyal plus
compliqué après son orageux et oui il ne
serait remise en question du grand val
d'isère ce cas les réseaux sociaux tout
a changé tout se sait en cinq minutes
avant laisse tout est beaucoup plus
compliqué les gens osent qu'augmenter
l'envoi des photos épouvantable tout le
monde dit oui c'est évidemment que ça va
être plus compliqué ça c'est ce qu'on
n'ose pas faire avec la règle dans le
frein avec le successeur d ce match est
ce qu'on n'ose pas faire avec la reine
on fera avec le successeur donc on s'est
un peu ce serait la fin d'une sorte de
depok douce on peut dire en tout cas
avec cette continuité qu'incarne cette
reine
ils font alors des prix tony pour
tourner deux guerres mondiales elle
était mécanicien donc je suis pas non
plus il va faire la réparation des
moteurs
et donc elle est acceptée aussi sans
papa est bon alors que 14 jours pour que
la terre fait pas un si long
garçons - ont
grandi avec ces trains entre yeu
autres sports qui ciblent le petit
prince charge petit prince à haïti est
devenu un champion olympique 1
dédication est donc pas quand on pas
assez puis le monsieur a ajouté le
moniteur au est
ce que ça veut dire tony scott shane est
ce que ça veut dire que on sait que
jeremy corps been par exemple donc était
le chef on est parti travailler vous
êtes travailliste aussi même si vous
n'êtes pas sur la ligne gerrie victor
been mais lui il aurait toujours permis
attendez excusez moi je suis la question
lui c'est un républicain il y en a
d'autres d'ailleurs au parti
travailliste est ce que la monarchie
après elizabeth 2 peut tenir
oui je crois patrick est au coeur du
candidat pris sa retraite puis
passait plus par qui n'a aucune
influence sur le télétravail
actuellement il n'y a pas si le bateau
jean lebelle offshore de la gauche
estime que 10 autres et on a avec à
l'arrêt en ligue
1 affiche dans le cité et conseil d'état
dit
impeccablement et les deux pas de là ils
essaient pas la dernière donc pour se
moquer de leigh day de continuation de
la monarchie il finirait tout laurent
grammont alors que terre ils sont peu
république parlementaire qui avait le
bon sens ce soir hier un mandat comme
chef des cactus aedificandi voudrais
savoir dans l'autre en plus qu'est-ce
que l'art est en étant vice le premier
ministre le pouvoir au fond
j'avais la vraie monarchie l'europe est
en tous les cas qu un président roy qui
a le pouvoir qu aucun loin et daniel
premier c'est la monarchie
présidentielle c'est ce que vous dites
une réaction qui est ce que la monarchie
va tenir des abeilles au cursus et là
dessus je pense que la monarchie vos
ateliers je pense que vaut mon les
potiers un écran moi j'ai tout de même
un cordon selon un sondage du sun 91 7 %
d'opinions favorables pour la reine
elizabeth 2 seulement 67 5% pour charles
67 c'est déjà pas mal il souhaitait pas
mal donc sondages c'est plutôt 50 ça va
tenir encore
la prime pour le sucre est en place si
l'avenir politique et avoir 65 ans
d'opinions favorables dans les sondages
donc vous révisez pense que la grande
bretagne n'est pas prêt à devenir une
république qu'on voit là le faste la
joie longvic de participer à tout ce
qu'on a vu aujourd'hui c'est jubilé
toutes les fêtes qui sont près de
programmer ce week-end dans les rues
j'ai du mal à croire que ça peut
s'arrêter du jour au lendemain donc pour
moi non
journée devant elle pierrick j'ai ouï
oui moi je pense que comme comme le
disais je en tout cas la monarchie en
angleterre a encore de beaux jours
devant elle après le royaume uni ça sera
peut-être plus compliqué par exemple
avec les expos et les écossais avec les
irlandais qu'est ce que vous en pensez
car une pique aux images je pense que
c'est un système qui est taillé pour les
anglais qui va tenir encore kid et
séculaires et qui va tenir et qui
tiendra donc avec charles avec williams
alors est-ce qu'elle va se moderniser
tout de même cette monarchie est ce que
parce que vous disiez de dispatching de
charles et finalement été le
conservateur mais comment se modernise
et qu'est ce qu'il fait mais je ne sais
pas des spectacles vous vous vous
aimeriez que la monarchie soit plus
moderne c'est ce que vous avez écrit
dans un papier tout récent
et que le préfet qui était le pilote
hélicoptère lors des chapeaux des îles
participer dans le placard et le cas
c'est pas lui qui avoue faire des
confrères parce que l'on à des photos de
[Musique]
ce qui est légal explique ceci peut être
à face à
un groupe a chuté d autrui pour la
première fois il va prendre ligne qu'on
copie chez huawei il va téléphoner en
biseau étude
commencée sur france 3 mireille est
normal parce qu'il avait tellement
l'habitude pour avoir
tenté des coups et donc qu'est-ce que
vous voulez
que je je pense
que ça sent la raid côtier ok tu as des
eaux
haut
savoyarde ce que vous avalez c'est ce
que vous avez dit donc mon il sera un
vieillard c'est un peu comme ça que vous
voyez là la reprise en tout cas par
charles de cette succession à mot de
conclusion peut-être philippe ils sont
peut-être vieux chien je pense à
repourvoir je n'ai pas de doute là
dessus il a quand même beaucoup
d'expérience dans le domaine il est ses
passions
donc comme je l'expliqué je pense que on
est en train de fêter la reine elizabeth
est extraordinaire c'est un personnage
unique et ben tant mieux pour elle et
vive la famille walt britannique pour
l'avenir merci beaucoup car une psychose
et d'avoir été avec no mercy avoue
philippe tort merci pierre que j'ai
merci d'aunis mcshane et merci à vous
tous de suivre est avec nous sur france
[Musique]